uh no time no time to talk really this
is the beginning of the mission
precipice of war oh [ __ ] gettin [ __ ]
sick uh my character here Donald Trump
he is ready for you [ __ ]
yep
oh yeah catgut yeah yeah okay okay every
ideas you got to do this Desdemona
Desdemona we're cut off the catacombs
are now our only way out glory was
guarding the entrance but she may
already be overwhelmed by the
Brotherhood I'll fight I'll clear the
katic do it secure the church [ __ ] had a
[ __ ] I get out here okay succinate
together goes
none of them got past me damn that
stings listen the railroad look great
promise me I promise hmm I've got Oh
baybay you pick the wrong door to go
through sir [ __ ]
okay then get my can age already that I
need I mean working aids where is that
good none of them got past me Tim
promise me you'll yes yes I promise I
prompt
who's next
yeah good look chicken ass out strong is
it insane
we take okay where are they Jesus I'm
here to execute it go this guy's gonna
get knocked out that's for sure no it's
the one thing they're gonna get that
next
gud gud good
this guy's gonna [ __ ] get it now okay
good now there's gonna be a big fight I
could feel it a big [ __ ] fight oh I
got some phlegm in my mouth oh [ __ ]
brother will crush the railroad
you got this dog you got this never give
up never gonna get back up there get
back up there John
get back in there strong get back in oh
[ __ ]
that [ __ ] get like sec
[ __ ] yeah okay talk to this Mona let's
do this [ __ ] is getting real real fast
okay okay which way I come from this way
special dead yet very sexy very sexy ya
know oh Jesus okay well quick site very
sad but also very sexy though you know
it's weird
what the hell's going on what the hell's
going on
where the heck is Brotherhood Jesus my
back is destined Anna she [ __ ] life I
told them this location wasn't safe is
she coming I what I wrote the [ __ ]
going on here no she's up there what the
[ __ ] if I wonder I guess glory like lost
all her clothes okay I have no idea like
those Brotherhood of Steel guys are
[ __ ] savages that's what it is okay
okay okay yeah chase oh geez no no this
way for nothing you've killed the last
of them and you're still standing I wish
the same could be said for glory the
Brotherhood underestimated so we do the
we eliminate the Brotherhood is that
threat now fortunately we've got a
contingent what what red glare requires
then whisper we'll get out on me with
what happened to the Brotherhood's
occupied the Cambridge police station
and Tom me no one else can fly that's an
ass Thank cans Damona my spirit sensors
I can prove that the institute is
terraform in the common will eat okay
guys we're in the thick of it
I gotta kill this guy he's see my face
okay what was that I just heard like a
dog get hurt mmm that that night is like
super hard yeah yeah yep get him get him
yeah yeah yeah yes Jesus thank you know
what you're shooting at me oh [ __ ] jay
says she need help
get-get gun what the [ __ ] okay what
about a meeting tinker tom why is he
[ __ ] all the way over there tom hey
how do you live up you there is a
million ways we could be monitored right
now by brotherhood or you know okay
there a shout the mission the police
station is crawling as promised uh-huh
that's guys let's go let's go prepping
that Berta Berta so first I can't
believe okay i'm pretty sure i did do
that tonight okay what's that dog in
there at least your dog
oh it's a mongrel that I [ __ ] cleared
it uh I guess like me inside ok let's do
this let's stay less chump isn't afraid
of change have this for sure he needs
drastic change okay whatta Freya okay
yeah yup you want one [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] if you know how to [ __ ] up high
in a war you're not just getting ready
Bella
Shay's ass yeah I didn't want to have to
do that but you know like desperate
times call for desperate measures
the [ __ ] is that
let's take it no mercy okay let's do
this let's do this I'm actually I pipe
but the yeah where's my purified water
fight cubes right here cuz i have so
much of it okay motor pool and get to
the roof [ __ ] that you that have a
[ __ ] the stairs here we go
intruder alert that [ __ ] it's a least
year proud you know kind of [ __ ] face
yeah good get got katka when every lot
outside it takes like 10 hours I forgot
I forgot
okay so how are we gonna have you aboard
this guy
anywhere yeah
this will be fun
Beckett hediye how can exit okay you fly
this [ __ ]
gotta go down now prior to going to
Facebook [ __ ] a
my headphones are get it [ __ ] up
got good
no I cool [ __ ] here huh huh all right we
get ourselves some wheels Oh a wings or
whatever to do kids do after flight prep
we take the vertebrate up to the bridge
wind from the inside the blips opponent
to keep that baby afloat it's got
massive gas bags full of hydro [ __ ] okay
good tell me about mom your job is true
you okay then get the hell back to our
vertibird black prep is sort out let's
tear this friday that's dead s okay
the [ __ ] where's that light come from
okay is there an easier way to get up
there then a [ __ ] right ok ok go back
in [ __ ] is that ok let's do this let's
do this tinker tom why did you call
taking our time to see tinkers with this
tom ok so that's my stuff ok ok let's do
this
okay okay let's do it okay hey there des
has given me clearance to set up my
atmospheric sense let's finish the
institute is terraform in the common
will eat that character can I get him to
mount hey Joe strong looked over here
leave it too strong so the manuals said
right move here you see a mountain well
you have to switch birdie-bird incoming
oil pressure check chef okay he's
hanging huh what's this panel you can do
throttle full open i'd say thats patches
this is half why matter what
yeah okay let's go baby let's go how's
Jane coming we're just trying to get off
he's I'm not [ __ ] doing that's god
dad let's go are we waiting for anytime
I guess I can take it right away all
right take all these guys okay
[ __ ] are we waiting for I'll talk with
Jay again
thank you